[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les yeux
battus la mine triste les
[Musique]
joublim tu ne sors plus tu n'es que
l'ombre de
toi-même seul dans la rue je re comme
une à mon
peine et tous les soirs sous ta fenêtre
je veux te
voir je sais bien que tu m'adores Dalida
Dalida et que j'ai des jolis yeux
DAA mais je suis trop jeune encore un
Ricot un Ricot pour jouer les
amoureux et grand grand sur ta guitare
mon
petitic ta musique est plus jolie que
toutes les filles de mon
pays
etaanta de ta
voixine
un
r je peux chanter ce que je veux
Davida moi tu ne me prends jamais
pour Cuse avec tes cheveux si
blancs tu as l'air d'un
chéri va plutôt jouer au
ballon comme font tous les bon
bain